hello everybody my name is markiplier
and holy crap we're starting right now
are we
oh god welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 4 bad oh it sounds like they're
in the room it really sounds like
they're in the room oh do not like that
it's when the running around it sounds
like they're right on top of me oh crap
oh man oh come on why do I have to go
through this hell why no you do not
what I do hi okay very cool what do I do
about that do the thinking I get out get
out get out
oh my god this is so horrible
this is so horrible okay we're okay
we're okay I don't know why keeps
flashing around my flashlights probably
dying [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
don't do that
okay all right okay okay okay okay
okay all right okay all right okay that
says something though that says
something the the fact that foxy in the
closet was foxy in the closet turned
into a plushy the longer I like looked
at him or each time I went back and
looked he turned into a plushie that's
important because that means this is all
really in this kid's head
he's like the origin of the nightmare
and why this is all going so wrong
because it's really like in his mind but
he's like had some traumatic experiences
and something has gone wrong to make him
turn his toys into these monsters and
he's like forced to go to Freddy
fazbear's that he doesn't like like all
that has real meaning and man if I could
just kept it up it would have been fine
I would have made it through the night
now I got to go through the whole thing
yeah oh man oh all right let's keep you
honor
this game was getting to me all this
game is messing with me oh this game is
digging with me how hard okay let's do
this but now I gotta get through the
whole night
I thought that was breathing I don't
know why I bothered checking
I should have err on the side of caution
okay all right now things are getting a
little more serious okay
starting to get a little later a little
bit later in the night but so far not so
bad nothing that I can't manage so long
as I know the rules I can play the game
okay that's a dink that's foxy trying to
get in cuz I don't think foxy got in
until I let I let him okay okay you am
where I want to start it with my head
start which would have been nice didn't
sound like it
god I need to wait longer God why am i I
wonder I really wonder if it's gonna be
a strategy to preemptively close the
door first until I hear breathing but I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to hear
breathing if the door is closed
cuz that may just block sound and I
wouldn't know anyway who knows let's
just wait damn it
okay he's in okay Foxy's in alright
Foxy's in hello foxy no you don't that
scary as hell okay yep you better okay
you better okay yeah you better no not
yet you better yeah okay he's better now
oh boy oh I didn't like that sound oh I
don't like that
that's breathing okay that was like
actually screaming like screaming in the
distance that I heard oh boy okay come
on Center center Center center okay I
don't have to get them all the way back
I don't think I think it's like a timer
- what was that
I heard a thing I think chicas like a
little quieter than [ __ ] bonnie is or
something I don't know
oh boy this is not happy fun times
jeezum 'he's okay okay okay okay man I
don't know how I'm gonna have enough
time for anything later on oh I do not
know I do not know
what kkkk dick would get out of here
down here here I don't know if that was
breathing or not but I'm not gonna take
a chance okay yeah you're foxy foxy foxy
let's go do it
[ __ ] Fox he's always gonna be unhappy
like a frickin towel okay fine fine fine
fine fine fine let's go go go go I don't
know why I always flies in like that I
don't like that I also don't like the
screaming in the distance prolly bad oh
god am i dead
am i already dead I don't know if I
might be already a dead oh it might be
like sister the North Star
I'm already dead I don't know I just
don't know that's the thing I just don't
know I don't know if I'm doing something
right
god I can never even look down the
hallway anymore okay what was that what
was that God am i doing something wrong
okay I think what I was doing wrong is
maybe maybe it was like with with foxy I
shut the door can I shut the door on the
other ones when they're screaming at me
I don't know I don't I don't think that
would be a thing but it's all it's
possible you have no idea what was that
was that the cupcake that's a cupcake
try to kill it is that a cupcake
murderer you don't know I don't know
this is a dog again no you don't you
don't you better get out of here doggie
there be monsters around here doggie
you better move on little dogie okay so
Bonnie's breathing and chicas breathing
are very different yeah okay so this
makes more sense
so the Bonnie's breathing in chicas
breathing are very different
chicas very light Bonnie's heavy but
sometimes chic is also heavy it's just
kind of dependent on which I don't know
if there's any rules about all I know is
that I'm gonna die okay
it's quiet really quiet
but god damn it [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah
you really gotta wait that's the thing
you gotta wait until he's gone
definitely gone or definitely the
breathing is happening was the flowers
flowers there weren't flowers there why
are there flowers there you guys saw
what I saw right there were flowers
there why were there flowers there if I
had known I would have clicked on him
yeah yeah okay okay okay I'm getting it
okay I think I got it now okay
there were flowers by the small teddy
bears I don't know what they meant
okay someone's getting close all right
not today crunch crunch crunch crunch
okay I'm starting to get it I get it I
start to get it I'm starting to get it I
really am okay all right
yes yes yes okay I get it I get it
I was thinking wrong I understand it now
I get the system I understand what it
wants from me and I understand how I'm
supposed to go about explaining it all
in a second okay I'll explain it all
when I get a chance here two days until
the party I don't know we already had a
party and it wasn't very fun oh boy he
hates you who does you have to get up I
know bad things are happening you can
get out this time but you have to hurry
okay Oh God who are you where is your
plush toy - spring Bonnie my dad says I
have to be careful with him our old
pinch my finger
he is a finger trap he says okay who's
that behind the thing no someone's
behind there what the hell wait what's
inside then hang on a second no don't
you remember all right okay I see
interesting so who are you
who are you whoa who are you you better
watch out I hear they come to life at
night and if you die they hide your body
and never tell anyone well that's a
little sinister why do you look so
worried see you at the party
hahaha thanks thanks thank you thank you
thank you hello
aren't you the kid who always hides
under the table and cries maybe maybe
not
haha no one else is scared why are you
stop being such a baby okay okay this is
a little bizarre this is more than a
little bizarre hello who are you why are
you crying
don't you like my toy collection I don't
know I really don't know yeah was there
another lake okay I see
a little worrisome oh my god it's
balloon boy haul balloon boy are you
going to the party everyone is going to
the party oh wait you have to go it's
your birthday
hahaha was happening Oh back home are we
be careful
picture who is what what do I have to be
careful with why does a kid have to be
careful in his own home oh man hello hi
I really want to know what that pot of
flowers was all about I know that had to
be a secret but I didn't I didn't get it
I didn't click on it I was worried about
other stuff like trying to survive oh ow
my throat tomorrow is another day
indeed it is oh yeah oh yeah I'm sure
this will work out in my favor
goddamn I sure wish I could do this
repeatedly Oh press x2 oh maybe I could
use it all the time who knows
whoa gotcha
[ __ ] me what the [ __ ] god damn it Oh
piece of [ __ ] criminy Christmas oh well
what else is new
Oh night for night for okay I'm just
gonna die horribly I know how to die
want to see how to die in a creative way
watch this it's gonna be fun nope nope
nope nope dump dump dump dump dump it
there for this game okay anyway my
thoughts on how to how this game
actually works okay so it's very finicky
it's it's actually it's not finicky at
all that's not the thing it's not that
it's finicky it's very picky on whether
you make the right choice or not there
are choices to be made when you open a
door you have to wait and listen and if
you do not hear that cue and you shut
the door
most likely they're gonna appear at the
door and if you open it they'll get you
so you have to make the right choice and
only only when they breathe could can
you close the door okay so that's what
that is all about and you have to listen
very carefully for it sometimes it'll be
right off the bat sometimes it'll be a
little bit later but you have to wait
for it no matter what with foxy that
self that's obvious that's obvious how
that goes but the plushies are what make
it blink more the more that they are
they are there they make it blink more
and eventually they'll kill you
so that's how that goes it's not like
finicky
it's just picky but it's it's what it is
it's not like random it's not nothing
it's picky it's very very picky on
whether you get it right or not so
either way thank you all so much for
watching check out the annotation for
more five nights at Freddy's stuff that
I've done hey I sang a song even it was
cool link in the description let me know
what you think in the comments down
below and as always I will see
in the next video